retrouvez donc au cinéma le grenier à
sel à trappes
trois films qui sont nos coups de coeur
de cette semaine tout d'abord nous vous
proposons de ma famille et le loup qui a
un film franco espagnole à une comédie
familiale qui on pouvait voir avec les
enfants à partir de
2 6 7 8 ans au problème on suit le petit
hugo qui a 9 ans et qui va passer les
vacances c'est chez sa mamie avec ses
cousins toute sa famille qui l'a pas vu
depuis très longtemps et la mamie leur
raconter un peu l'histoire familiale et
leur raconte que le lou va venir la
chercher
donc allez un petit peu âgées on imagine
tout ce que pour présenter le loup et
parle aussi du grand père et toute leur
histoire familiale et donc les enfants
tous les cousins vont se souder ils vont
être très solidaire pour combattre le
loup et protéger la famille et la mamie
c'est une très très belle histoire
familiale avec un mélange un peu
d'animation et de et de prises de vues
réelles
donc on vous conseille ma famille et le
loup nous avons aussi cette semaine
roubaix une lumière dernier film de
arnaud despléchin qui était en
compétition au festival de cannes
c'est un super polar avec roschdy zem
en policier à découvrir absolument
un autre coup de coeur de cette semaine
c'est 303 c'est une romance sous forme
de road movie
donc c'est un film allemand avec deux
jeunes qui traverse l'espagne
l'allemagne la belgique la france pour
aller jusqu'en espagne et qui refont le
monde c'est très grosse et très tendre
et
et on a très envie de repartir en
vacances avec eux vous retrouvez donc
ces trois films ma famille le loup
roubaix et 303 au cinéma le grenier à
sel je vous dis à très vite
[Musique]